[Musique]
n'importe qui je vous répète n'importe
qui peut contracter la punaise des lits
et l'a ramené en son domicile
il faut évacuer l'idée reçue que c'est
une insectes associé à la mauvaise
hygiène
[Musique]
c'est visible à l'oeil nu et en fait
vous avez des signes que sont les
conséquences des piqûres ça des petites
taches de sang sur les draps ou alors
des lieux d'agrégats de punaises des
lits où elle se concentre autour des
têtes de lit sommier chevet autour du
dormeur ou la punaise des lits et les
insectes les plus difficiles à traiter
de par son mode de vie et sa biologie
donc faut prendre ça au sérieux ça ne
propagent pas de maladie selon les
scientifiques et médecins ou
parasitologue que nous avons dans notre
entourage
par contre il y a des conséquences
psychologiques jusqu'à des dépressions
graves des cas de stress intense
[Musique]
le premier moyen c'est de s'informer de
savoir ce contre quoi on va on veut
lutter ou se prémunir ensuite quand vous
voyagez vous allez vous allez pouvoir
éventuellement prendre la précaution
n'avait votre linge à 60 degrés ce qui
fait que vous éliminez au moins sur vos
vêtements les risques de diffusion et de
de propagation dans un appartement
le fait de jeter directement le mobilier
effectivement c'est une solution ultime
on s'en débarrasse au cap une punaise
mais faut pas penser que c'est que dans
le mobilier attention ça peut être dans
la structure de votre appartement
donc un exemple si vous jetez une tête
de lit et des cheveux et un sommier un
matelas et que l'infestation est dans
les murs ou dans le mouvement de
plancher vous aurez fait quelque chose
d'inutile et là ce qu'on vous conseille
c'est de faire appel à un expert parce
que la chose sérieuse
[Musique]
ça va des lieux d'habitation des lieux
d'hébergement des foyers des prisons des
hôpitaux des crèches des maisons de
retraite des lieux de culture des moyens
de transport enfin bref partout où on va
pouvoir passer
elles sont plus ou moins là des degrés
divers
on n'est pas égaux devant les
conséquences une personne qui n'a pas
les moyens d'engager des traitements
derrière forcément elle risque de rester
longtemps avec ces punaises et de
diffuser si elle dans un appartement au
reste de la collectivité
la présence de punaises